my name is Chris Cheung hello everyone
I'll discuss my research findings on the
historical sources formation usage and
meanings of China's u-shaped line claim
in the South China Sea dispute however I
will broadly an theoretically frame the
discussion in terms of discourse and
history but first why history
why does course I mean don't they just
seem to complicate the issue even
further I focus on them because the
islands disputes in China is
fundamentally such an issue China's
government and large segments of the
populace wholeheartedly believed islands
are intrinsic territory now accepting
this narrative blindly or dismissing it
as mere a hodgepodge is to miss the
narratives own rich discursive history a
history of histories if you will as
present jadoo era notes in rescuing
history from the nation national
narratives are bifurcated inner I'm
gonna and by this I mean while they seek
to project a neat stable teleological
history that progresses forward you know
linearly it also reads history for the
needs of the present its us collects
constructs and manipulates spatially and
chronologically dispersed pasts into its
timeline these narratives take a life of
their own various states and non-state
actors constantly wrestle with
perpetuate contest and mold them through
time by constructing other discourses
some become more dominant than others
and naturalize historically contextual
actions that color the way national
subjects interprets an act this is all
the more so and something as
historically nationalistic ly and
politically charged as the South China
Sea dispute changing Chinese conceptions
of geography and history sovereignty and
borders the many interpretations of the
u-shaped line how various segments of
Chinese society manipulates existing
historical narratives beyond original
intentions to create new ones that
affect state actions rhetoric these are
more problematize any monolithic and
static characterization of how China
views doubts the above is why discourse
is central to understanding the dispute
to fully grasping the substantial role
it plays in Chinese political
self-identity and definitions of
political interests and priorities
it is these multiple mechanics of
course change ambivalence contestation
perpetuation and appropriation that I
will attempt to very broadly touch upon
him the remaining time that I have left
I begin with don't I wanna talk calls
concept at the Geo body or the
geographic aspects of the nation it
envisions a clearly bounded spatial
political entity imagined through such
mediums as maps and gazetteers and this
conception of the geo body however was
initially Western and adopted by China
in earnest only by the late 19th century
Chinese intellectuals then widely
believed their state had to incorporate
Western tenets of modernity in order to
strengthen itself against foreign
imperial ventures especially Westphalian
like sovereignty several scholars on
Imperial Chinese cartography and
geography such as Richard Smith Laura
Hostetler and Emma Tong agreed a prior
to this time vague frontiers and subject
based sovereignty dominated Imperial
Chinese imaginaries of the Empire's
limits frontiers centered on natural
features such as mountains rivers
deserts but especially the ocean the
coast was the only thing serving as any
clear boundary line and change Chinese
cartography gazetteers and travel
writing tongue for instance in Taiwan's
imagined geography outlines the
formidable discursive obstacle that the
ocean posed to change full incorporation
and development to Taiwan from seventeen
to mid nineteenth century
it took two centuries of Pro colonial
ethnographies and travel writing to
overturn popular conceptions of Taiwan
as a distance inhospitable worthless all
of mud much of this idea of Taiwan's
alien nature was based on how far lay
beyond discursive imagining of Hawaiian
or other seas and immediate Imperial
realm encapsulated within an eon or
inner seas my own research shows the
primacy and limited geographic extent of
his new young Hawaiian for instance let
me show you this map spread of hong kong
in a naval defense gazetteer that the
governor-general's the guanxi and
guangdong province luc1 and dong ting
Jang completed in 1838 it is titled a
compendium of maritime defense of
Guangdong or excuse my horrible Mandarin
pronunciation Guangdong - Whelan here
you can see the repetition of the
characters why
okay so like why I'm here sometime why
and Hong Kong addressees by young here
why I'm here from this island island and
respectively so you'll notice that it's
extremely limited in geographic extent
now to me it this speaks volumes already
on how to chain conceived at a South
China Sea Islands
unlike Taiwan the Spratlys lie several
hundreds more miles self into ocean and
wasn't inhabitable for long official PRC
position papers and pro-chinese scholars
Mendel s often point to several genera
Geographic gazetteers and maps as
evidence of China's perennial and
effective occupation of the at once this
is an example of the nationalist
bifurcation that I talked about earlier
and you attempt to establish a teleology
of China's perennial claim these
discourses see in any historical mention
of the islands proof of Chinese control
over them
ideas that a geo body are employed to
characterise differing Qing conceptions
of geography so for instance many talk
of how so-and-so lurched in gazetteer or
map mentioned Islands therefore it had
to be change I need these Chang
historical sources that pro-chinese
argument it's often referred to however
to me only suggest historical awareness
for instance I found that major Qing era
gazetteers and naval defence menus such
as gender and Jung's records of sights
and sounds of the maritime countries or
hyegyo in general in 1730 ca-ching Gao
and Yong ping ons
maritime records or Hailu in 1844 and
wayans Illustrated gazetteer of the
maritime countries hi pooja or yeah in
1847 display three common themes talons
were out of route markers that weren't
to be traveled to or pass closely by and
for reasons which the second theme
covers which is danger it's to be
avoided at all costs it's not something
that's part of the normal maritime
routes that's
hugged south southeast china coast and
eastern Vietnamese coast and along the
southeast asian states and third dots
these islands were natural modes by like
moats you don't station
Sandow they were there because as a
defense of natural defensive feature
because of its hostile environment so
seon-young and maritime records Harlow
was very straightforward those that
strayed straight is word that they use
into the area would be smashed to pieces
by the shallows and angry waves official
PRC position papers and pro-chinese
scholars point out several Ching maps as
proof but simply list their appearance
as sufficient discounting the
intricacies of chain cartographic
representation and conceptions of
frontiers
so you see here for instance the
universal map of the Qing Empire 1767 I
got this from a pamphlet when I was
visiting Taipei 2012-2013 so a pamphlet
is on an exhibition of chain cartography
so you'll note here with like say the
red line here in the little circles with
legend over there that's added later so
discount that so you'll see here for
instance when I was talking about
earlier with natural frontiers mountain
Rangers deserts and you'll see around
here is where a lot of probe PRC sources
would say that's where the South China
Sea Islands were represented so if you
zoom in here and you'll see this is a
one liter selling sheet on roughly 1000
roughly translated 10,000 miles shoals
and sandbanks
yeah so the idea is okay well you see
this and okay that means that has to be
in there but again this as I mentioned
earlier it's you're reading geo body
discourses into anachronistically into
chain representation so here for
instance you don't know whether this is
actually part of China or not just as
you don't know what are these other
features all along here or there or here
and our Chinese I'm here I should have
actually put a close-up but that's where
the where Europe was represented as
various islands and various states
smushed into one entity or two entities
so basically yeah you see this reading
of Geo body discourses you get this by
the 1911 revolution where Chinese
discourses have bought into the Geo body
of this course from the 1910 to 1930 s
we see geographers like by me to drawing
unofficial maps in a self-perceived duty
to enunciate every square inch of
China's territory to fight or guard
against imperialism maps gradually
extended China southernmost territories
from the Paracels and practice islands
in 1914 to the Spratlys in 1935 bill I
don't know if you're gonna be talking
about but I assume you are so I he'll
probably cover that in more depth than I
will so now we get to the u-shaped line
because of time purposes I practice
certain maps but again it's this idea
that's here with the chunks and [ __ ] Tom
you just it's so you get to a u-shaped
line here
my recently published article drawing
the u-shaped line with the journal
modern China goes through ROC national
archival files on the formation and
early usage of the u-shaped line for
1946 honor curiously enough English and
Chinese language source a scholarship
secondary scholarship on the u-shaped
line don't seem to go through this and
so I figured why not go to the source a
very soon now to me they reveal a
nationalist discursive process so for
example ROC Survey reports on Islands
usually began with historical summaries
a balance to justify to the executive
young the executive branch at ROC
civilian governments the need to
effectively occupy develop and protect
them several talk about islands always
be in Chinese or informed by historical
records since the Song Dynasty keep in
mind these reports were with written
shortly after the Second World War
Japan surrendered meant two islands were
now empty as Japan during the war had
occupied them
Darcie archives events the nationalist
imagining and concern such as a
perceived need to quickly reclaim what
it saw as its centuries-old territory
shortly after the Second World War
given the proximity of England and
Borneo and France and Vietnam and the
threat that that would take them over
now I don't know how much time left to
go through my articles coverage of the
history of the u-shaped line in debt
well I say a few few very general things
too broadly frame my discussion at
discourses dynamism and multi sudden
nature drawing on an RSC National
Archive of files that remain virtually
and used by scholars on a dispute I
argue that the line served as an island
attribution boundary until at least 1974
it claimed only two islands features and
any adjacent waters consistent with
contemporary conceptions of
international maritime law whether our
CR international it is opposed to a
historic rights framework which sees the
line as claiming exclusive economic and
exploration rights within all the waters
based on historic domination so here are
some of the maps that's covered that
detailed of formation of it so this is a
rough draft of the u-shaped line in 1946
same with this one
1947 and then you gets to the present
day one so for me there are four themes
that show that save with this these are
accomplished the files show that's an RC
wasn't initially interested in claiming
of comprehensive maritime regime so one
they don't never talk about a
comprehensive waters regime to begin
with which is extremely significant
given that the explicit purpose of these
reports and conference minutes
what's the detail what exactly was to be
incorporated officially as the knurled
by the u-shaped line and now
specifically to show effective
occupation a September 1946 conference
in particular is instructive as a
clearly states that the u-shaped line
was to show the scope of all the islands
and only islands to be recover from
Japan secondly these files show that
Darcy never sought to adopt its own ship
never sought to transfer for itself
Japan's wartime administration of
islands called the Chenango in tow so
which because they're still not good
this is significant because the Chenango
till may have may or may not have
delineated of water zone around it but i
argued that the files showed that they
were just interested in reclaiming what
they thought was the status quo prior to
world war ii third the physical
attributes of the u-shape
in particular as you'll see you in the
blue circle there there's a little
branch dorrance marked the same pattern
as all the rest of the u-shaped line and
it's funny to me because almost no
scholars point this out but my research
it didn't adhere really to any ROC
contemporary ROC or international
conceptions of maritime boundaries so
and to me it just seems more focused on
deal inning which islands or whose so
that has to avoid confusion so and
finally there's a complete lack of any
assertion that the u-shaped line was
China's Truman Proclamation in 1945 in
which the u.s. unilaterally declared a
continental shelf waters regime plus to
me a my mind preclude ability that's the
two can be completed so the PRC to me
fault the same islands attribution
reading since its adoption align for
1949 to 1974 a particular notice the
PRC's declaration or territories in 1958
which indirectly asserted that a belt of
high seas existed between the Chinese
mainland and Islands
this all changed in 1974 for reasons
that are still not entirely sure
since then the PRC has maintained
official ambiguity as to what specific
waters and rights it claims within the
u-shaped line it only ever claims
adjacent pertinent or relevant waters
without specifying the geographical
scope and specific rights involved now
to conclude this presentation I want to
delve quickly into what about everybody
else it seems that I'm only talking
about elites and official discourses but
to me everyone else has a part to play
too in the PRC our state proliferated
nationalist discourses sure especially
as results of the patriotic national
education campaign in 1991 but even
these discussed eight discourses get
appropriated molded and received by der
targets and ways unintended ways that
can go against state directors or as
desires popular protests can for example
become grow out of hand and become
opposition to the CCP for being too soft
under on enforcing what they see as
intrinsic territory a discourse
ironically enough that was probably
propagated initially by state discourses
now Jessica to advise a scholar in
Chinese nationalism a pines that things
are a little more complex than this
the CCP after all can always net
protests at the bun however she knows
that is still exercised a caution when
exercising their power frequents or
uninformed use of it may potentially
feel further Nationals backlash or at
least greatly damaged a legitimacy that
rests so heavily on patriotism the CCP
also has to allow certain amounts of
conflicting discourses otherwise other
powers will think that's not genuine
so when CCP says oh look at these
national discourse as our hands are tied
then states may not believe them because
do you think are there just fabricate or
manufactured some academics also problem
ties feature CCP efforts at officially
enunciated in what waters regime may
claims ons attribution and historic
white scholarship are both allowed in a
PRC but the idea that the PRC is
entitled to some sort of historic rights
has already gained much ground in a
popular imaginaries of Chinese and non
sending in islands attribution position
thus could mean selling out the country
it is hope from this overview that
Chinese discourses on a cell chonsy
dispute is anything but static and
monolithic it is a discursive history
that it is rich in so many ways
dynamic multi sourced and ambivalence
thank you for your time
you